there have been many people who have
made waves this year and moved us
angered us inspired us uplifted us but
few were true badasses oh I'm sorry did
I break your concentration here AJ
pluses top five badasses of 2014 to
millions this new pope is kind of dope
as they say last year he washed women
prisoners feet this year he demoted a
cardinal for being anti-gay said it's
alright to cohabitate with your
boyfriend or girlfriend and told world
leaders to take care of the earth so it
does not respond with destruction while
no one officially knows who the hackers
are fingers are pointing to North Korea
it's one of the biggest cyber attacks on
a huge corporation in history private
emails executive salaries and copies of
Sony's not yet released movies all have
been leaked and boy did we learn a lot
like what jerks some of the top
Hollywood execs can be okay maybe that
isn't much of a surprise but just how
magical a Channing Tatum email can be a
few dead second of all time biatch come
on jumps readers we got Cate Blanchett
with this box office bitches
november the fillet made history when it
landed on a face of a comet that is
speeding through deep space this was the
first time a spacecraft ever landed on a
comet and didn't crash it descended from
the European Space Agency mothership
spacecraft Rosetta landing on the
thrillingly named comet 67p over 300
million miles away from Earth high-five
to those scientists the jury is still
out on this guy's shirt though after 29
year old Brittany Maynard learned she
had terminal brain cancer and six months
to live she moved to Oregon where
physician assisted suicides are legal I
will die upstairs in my bedroom that I
share with my husband um with my mother
and my husband by my side and passed
peacefully with some music that I like
in the background Brittany was
determined to end her life by November
the first and she did the young women of
the Ferguson protest are showing us what
democracy looks like always on the front
line and with the loudest voices they've
emerged as the leaders in the black
lives matter movement let me help you we
can't get her together because somebody
gotta get a say
let's get there so those were our
badasses of 2014 who are yours here are
the top 5 jerks of 2014 it was pretty
hard for us to pick our top five heroes
of 2014 but here it goes